foreign
I was gonna say everybody's favorite
segment or nobody's favorite segment the
new segment called facts are your
friends
look at this cool little thing over here
that looks awesome way to go
who made that backdrop
Siders but it's been a while so we've
had it amazing awesome back to your
friends all right
so
I'm kind of breaking my own rule here
and here's what it is
I don't usually like to read old things
unless they're old nerd articles
and I don't like to
I don't like click baity stuff and I
don't like to get on that rabbit hole
because I've learned from my journalist
friends that a lot of things they write
they don't even believe in them they
because their job isn't to write
articles that are believable their art
their job is to get clicks and so they
make things the most clickbaity but
enough of you sent me this article and I
guess it's like an editorial piece and
it's old it's a year old it's from it's
almost a year and a half June 16th 2021.
and I'm not even going to give the
author's name because I don't want to
give this author credence
the name of the article is called don't
play with your kids
seriously that's the name of the article
don't play with your kids seriously
[Music]
here's the way the article goes
my older son recently made a vending
machine out of a cardboard box my
daughter created clothing for her
Barbies out of paper and tape by the way
it's the New York Times
my baby went through the hall closet
describing the shoes in a babble that
was only 1 8 English
all three participate in a steampunk
inspired world of their own creation
yada yada
their games are going well the kids are
murmuring saying to one another pretend
we or what if we or the queen must be
assassinated lots of screaming meanwhile
I'm doing the crossword
the author goes on to say and this is
verbatim
I have three kids under 10 who don't
expect or even want to play with me it
took some practice but over time we've
all learned we're better off doing our
own thing the kids without stodgy
parental interference and my husband and
I unhooked from the assumption that we
have to play to be present
now here's why I'm choosing a comment on
this and a facts of your friends segment
this is the kind of arrogant over
academization
and this is Two Guys a guy with two phds
I know academics
this is somebody who has thought
themselves into a pretzel
and has created an outcome academically
that they wanted
and as
reverse engineered this narrative that
this makes some sort of sense
in its insanity
it's Madness
and quite honest it's heartbreaking goes
on to say it wasn't always this way as a
toddler
um
my first child wasn't digging in the
trash or chewing on the couch cushions
he was rampaging through the house with
an imaginary weapon he never listened
because he was a toddler
may try to run into traffic because he's
a toddler it's what they do the constant
wrangling and vigilance was so
exhausting
you mean parenting that my husband and I
didn't have the energy to play the way
my son preferred anything that involved
full body contact or pretend violence
instead I said no and stop all day long
you mean instead of putting down the
crossword puzzle and getting on all
fours and making eye contact with your
son and touching him on the face and
letting him feel seen and heard
that just would have been too
inconvenient because you're working on
the crossword puzzle
I was a terrible Playmate I felt guilty
and frustrated a tired mother who did
little Beyond obstructing
so you quit on him
you quit on him
he's just too hard it's too rambunctious
too energetic
but when I my son was about three I
realized his fictive worlds were vivid
enough to continue without me all he
needed at first was a listener
after a while he would head into his
bedroom alone to transform it into a
place that lived in his mind
this my friends is a trauma response
this is a child who is desperately
trying to make connection with the
adults in its life in his life
and whose adults are too busy with the
crossword puzzle or Instagram or their
show or work or their weight loss
program or their working out program or
whatever else they're focused on
and there comes a point
that a child will fold in on himself or
herself
head off alone
into a room
and their body will compress their
feelings
and will Channel them inside their own
mind
little by little my husband and I would
stretch the time our son could safely
play by himself it was freedom for all
of us
is insanity yes young kids can learn to
play by themselves and it's important
that they develop autonomy and all that
that's fine
but the idea that you're taking a
three-year-old and teaching them to be
alone
this is the Cornerstone of selfishness
and Madness
it's Madness
when you have a kid you give up the
crossword puzzle
adults
when you have a kid that's rambunctious
you join in with them
you don't beat it out or neglect it out
of them
when you have a child who is quiet and
reserved
you dude I listened to 90s country on
the way to work sometimes do you think I
like it no I want to set my eardrums on
fire
but my son loves it and I'm making
connections with him
the other day we spent nine hours nine
agonizing hours in the woods hunting
you know what came out no things nothing
I would have given up and left and when
I said hey you want to go
no dad no it's good this is good for us
so I sat with him hour after hour
because my presence
is a gift
do I like it no am I perfect that I'm
terrible at it I'm working on this all
the time
but I'm not partnering with my wife to
see how we can slowly reduce the amount
of time that our kids have access to us
so that they in turn have to figure out
how to do life alone
look around we've created the loneliest
generation in human history with this
kind of nonsense
here it goes uh I can be critical I'm
distracted by work and life I have a bad
temper and I don't like to play
especially pretend or anything with
dolls or figures or any games that ask
me to hide or wield a Nerf gun gun my
motto is moms don't play
the other context also applies I do not
play
I can't say my Approach is right for
everyone it's a right for No One
because when you have kids
foreign
here's here's the most important part
I know that it resonates for me in part
because of how I was raised I have no
memories of my parents playing with me
I can remember reading together and
they're swimming with me in the ocean
but they weren't involved in the fashion
shows I filmed with my sisters and they
didn't help me make my magazine kid
stuff either
not once did they dine at my fictional
restaurant
could this be why as an adult
your kids have a mom that doesn't play
or that you're critical and have a bad
temper you're distracted by work because
you have a little child inside
wondering what is so bad about my little
restaurant that my parents won't even
bother to come see me
what is it about me that's so bad that
my parents won't play
what is so awesome about that crossword
puzzle
that makes it more worthy of my mom and
dad's attention than me
and that makes for an exhausted bitter
critical angry adult
maybe you're the living result of your
relationship free childhood Maybe
that's not fair
but when I see this kind of gymnastic
nonsense it's academic gymnastics
really I don't want to be bothered by my
kids because they're annoying to me
kids are boring they're messy they're
loud they're rambunctious they run into
traffic or they just sit there and do
nothing they poop 111 times a day
they're annoying they're bothering me
so I'm going to
work backwards and create a narrative
that makes this all okay
oh they don't want to even play with me
they just want to sit in their own mind
in their room alone
it's nonsense
parents
do the exact opposite of this article
play with your kids
invite your kids with you everywhere you
possibly can it's gonna take longer it's
going to be annoying there's going to be
certain conversations you can't have
because your kid's sitting right there
and if you really have to have a deep
hard private conversation cool go have
adult time that's awesome that's
important
my wife and I do couples dates and we
all go out to restaurants no kids it's
great but if I'm going to help a buddy
of mine fix a thing my kid comes with me
if I'm going hunting with a buddy my kid
comes with me
if I need to go get the car worked on my
kids come with me because I need them to
see how the world works and how their
dad interacts with adults and how their
mom interacts with
play with your kids and there's times
that get on all fours and I'm sitting at
a restaurant and my daughter I don't
understand what we're eating I don't
understand what we're doing I think
there's wolves and Dragons running
around I don't know what's happening but
I'm there
and I'm not a great parent
but I understand the neurodevelopmental
importance of this the socio psychosa
the psychosocial development I'm just
getting so frustrated listen moms and
dads
play with your kids
be present with your kids
let your kids not just see but feel how
valuable they truly are teach them about
relationship teach them about connection
teach them about relationships that are
more important
in the crossword puzzle and if you find
yourself bitter or critical or angry or
someone in a dad who just doesn't play
be an adult
and work on those things
do what you can to heal be less critical
be more supportive
you don't know how to play learn how to
play
parents
play with your kids seriously